Why is IP6 good for cancer patients?
Well, I think I have some videos on IP6, but I think I have blog posts on IP6 and cancer as well
But IP6 has an ostitol in it and that's a forum
It's actually a form of sugar
that helps
helps the structure of your cells and
it
helps with
It can help with brain issues and call me your brain again. That's you know, that's not specifically for cancer
But it can be extremely call me to the brain. It can be helpful for
people with panic attacks, anxiety issues, depression issues, OCD issues
IP6 is
beneficial for cancer because it has immune stimulating properties that can help bring up your immune system can increase white blood cell production
It has been showed in studies to
stimulate
extrinsic apoptosis
and
So it could help kill cancer cells directly
So IP6 is a good supplement. I am a lot of people on it. It's one of those supplements that anybody
really could take
And it's not it's not going to be something that's going to overwhelm your liver
so that's
That's IP6